you may not believe it but there is  magic all around us  there are times it can be hard to find  did you bring your garbage to school  but sometimes stuff the magic  finds us look at you  number casey so cute i'm so red  how big is he gonna get that depends  doesn't it unless  on how much you love him i wish you were  big and strong  and the world could nervous  [Music]  oh we're gonna be late for school  [Music]  [Music]  shouldn't we try to hide him or  something it's new york  don't even know this pizza just a big  whoo why don't we get you on the scale  here bud  i'm just gonna write  what if heavy found someone who made you  feel like you could do anything  [Music]  clickers  this dog is killing me  oh look they're playing  well you don't see that every day maybe  it's time to feed him